مئه يوم مره منذ دلاع الاحتجاجات في ايران
بعد مقتل الشابه الكرديه ماسا اميني لدى
شرطه الاخلاق مظاهرات مستمره ولا يبدو
انها ستنتهي قريبا هذا وشاهدت مناطق على
الاقل في العاصمه طهران ومدن ايرانيه اخرى
بما في ذلك كرج وسندج واصفهان ومشهد وبندر
عباس مظاهرات واحتجاجات مناوعه للنظام
الايراني وتحولت الساحات في ايران من رقع
المكتظه بالمتظاهرين الى ميادين موت علني
بالرافعات وساحات للاعدام في محاوله من
النظام لترهيب المحتاجين الامر الذي اثار
انتقادات دوليه وداخليه اخر قرارات القضاء
الايراني عقوبه الاعدام بحق الطبيب
الايراني جار حصل له بتهمه المشاركه في
اعمال عنف رغم مساعدته عضوا من الجهاز
الامني الايرانيه البسيج فقالت صحيفه
واشنطن بوست ان قوه الامن الايرانيه دهمت
منزل الطبيب وزوجته قالتهما وضربتهما امام
ابنتهما البالغه من العمر 14 عاما
[موسيقى]
ونناقش الموضوع من بيروت مع حسن فحص
الكاتب الصحفي ومن لندن عبر خدمه
الايراني
كيف تقيم حجمه وتاثيره هذه المظاهرات
اليوم
تحياتي لك يا استاذ صهيب الاستاذ يوسف
عزيزي
والمشاركين والمشاهدين
يعني في التقييم الاول
لما حدث خلال ال 100 يوم من اندلاع شراره
الانتفاضه الشعبيه يمكن قول انها استطاعت
تحقيق ما تريد من خلال فرد ارادتها على
النظام بان
يتراجع عن الزاميه الحجاب الذي رفعت اولاد
المطلب الذي رفع منذ بدايه الاحتجاجات
يعيد النظر
بالكثير من سيادته وان لم يكن الكلام
علانيا عن هذه اعاده النظر ولكنها بدات
بالفعل همم ولكن في خلف الكواليس همم
نتيجه همم تركيبه النظام الذي لا يمكن ان
يعترف بانه وقدم تنازلات همم لذلك يعمل
الى العمل من خلف الستار
للتعاطي مع هذه التطورات وهذه الاحتجاجات
ومطالبها همم
المختل الاساس التي حققها حققتها هذه
الاحتجاجات وهذه التظاهرات هي انها ادخلت
النظام في همم تحدي واضح حول الهويه همم
العقائديه والديولوجيه له همم خاصه وانها
كشفت عن وجود انفصام
وانفصال بين الاجيال الاولى التي حملت
المشروع الاسلامي الدوله
والاجال الجديده التي تريد ان تذهب بعيدا
في المطالبه بحريتها الشخصيه والاجتماعيه
والحريه التعبير وحريه الراي هو التعدديه
سياسيه
ولذلك همم هذه التحديات همم تربك النظام
ولكن همم
قد تكون على مم يعني سكه المعالجه همم
وتجبره على التقديم بعض التنازلات هي تربك
النظام الايراني اسالك همم في ذات السياق
كذلك الاستاذ يوسف عزيزي في لندن هذه
المظاهرات همم كان هناك توقعات بانها
ستنحسن ربما في غضون اسابيع ولكنها هي
الان تستمر لاكثر من 100 يوم ولم تاخذ
منطقه جغرافيه واحده بل هي همم عمت عديد
المناطق همم الايرانيه همم كيف يمكن النظر
الان الى حجم الارباك الذي يتحدث عنه
الاستاذ حسن في بيروت للنظام الايراني
بسبب هذه المظاهرات حتى الان
اهلا وسهلا بكم
وبضيفكم السيد حسن فحوص
ومشاهديكم الكرام
يعني
هذه
الانتفاضه الكبرى
في الواقع هي ايييي جمع من الانتفاضات
السابقه
الانتفاضات السابقه التي حدثت في 2009
و2/2017 و2019 كانت اما فيها الطبقه
الوسطى وان ما فيها الطبغات المسحوره الان
جميع هذه الطبقات بدات يعني تتشابك ايدها
وتنتفض ضد النظام لكن لكن
هذه الثوره ليست مباراه 100 100 متر هذه
قلتها انا من هذه القناه سابقا هذه في
الواقع مباراه ماراثون همم وهذه الثوره
قبل ان تحدث في الشارع حدثت في طول
والافكار والاثان بين الشباب بين النساء
بيننا الجيل التسعينيات والذي هو في
الواقع الاكثر همم في الشارع فا هناك
استشهد ايران نهضه
همم هذه النهضه ست- ستعوز ليس فقط النظام
الايراني بنيت الدوله
انت هنا تتفق مع الاستاذ حسن انه المساله
ابعد من الزاميه الحجاب او ممارسات شرطه
الاخلاق التعسفيه همم
المجتمع الايراني تغير هناك جيل جديد لم
يعش ثوره همم
الخميني في 79 وبالتالي هذا الجيل يريد
نظاما اخر هل يمكن القول هذا
نعم ليس نظام اخر بل بني للنظام الدوله
الامويه في ايران اخر انتم لا تنظرون لا
تنظروا فقط للظهران الان الثوره هي بدات
من كردستان من المحيط من بين الاكراد
واستمرت الى بلوشستان والى عربستان والى
اذربيجان
خراسان وسائر المدن لكن ثقل الثوره ومبدا
الثوره من مناطق غير الفارسيه وهو لم يحدث
لا في ثوره الدستور
1909 ولا في ثوره ثوره الاسلاميه 1979 هذه
ظاهره جديده همم عن هذه النقطه الاستاذ
حسن فحص في بيروت همم مساء مين هي فتاه
كرديه والمساله متعلقه بلباس المراه
والحجاب الالزامي الذي تفرضه شرطه الاخلاق
وتعاقب عليه بقسوه في ايران المفروض انه
المظاهرات ست في هذا الاطار ربما همم
الاطار الكردي دعنا نقول او ربما الاطار
النساء لماذا اتسعت رقعه هذه الاحتجاجات
اولا الى كل المناطق الايرانيه
ولتذهب المطالبات ابعد من حل شرطه الاخلاق
فقط بل الى تغيير النظام برمته
يعني من الطبيعي يعني تبدا همم الثوره او
الانتفاضه في همم في مكان وتتسع وتتسع
مطالبها ويمكن ان تبدا بمطلب بسيط جدا همم
كما حدث في تونس مثلا اعتراض على صفع
الشرطي
بائع الخضار ولكنها تتحولت هذه الصفحه
تحولت الى ثوره همم
المدخل الذي حرك الشارع هو مقتل ماسا على
يد شرطه الاخلاق من بوابه الحجاب
والزاميه الحجاب وممارسات شرطه الاخلاق
همم ضد همم
مع النساء اللاتي لا تلتزمنا بالحجاب
المطلوب او المطلوب
وتوسع المطالب وكل وكل واحد في اي ثوره له
مطالب يخرج منه من اجلها
وتتوسع دائره المطالب الا ان همم يعني هذه
المطالب همم
الدودييتها من الحجاب الى الى الحريات الى
الى همم
الجيل الشباب المتطلع
للمزيد من الانفتاح همم هذه بحدثتها هي
تشكلت همم مطالب المرحله الجديده في ايران
التي لم يراها ولم يراها النظام في
المرحله السابقه واعتبر ان قيادته لهذا
النظام
والسياسات الداخليه والسياسات الاقتصاديه
تكفي همم لاسكات الناس ولكن
بالاضافه الى ممارسات القمعيه التي اسكت
جميع الاصوات حتى المعتدله منها حتى التي
لا تعارض اساس النظام اسكتها لصالح راي
واحد واتجاه واحد لذلك
بحجم هذه همم الحراك وحجم مطالبه
والتحديات التي خلقها له همم الاستاذ لندن
هذا القمع الذي يتحدث عنه الاستاذ حسن من
قبل النظام الايراني ومفاجاته او تفاجئه
هذه
المظاهرات المستمره كان هناك قمع شديد
وهناك همم عمليه اعدام واحكام اعدام ما
تزال مستمره همم كذلك برايك لماذا لا توقف
لم توقف كل هذه الاجراءات من قبل النظام
الايراني لم توقف استمرار خروج المتظاهرين
المواطن الايراني قرر بعد كل الانتفاضات
المنتكسه السابقه فاشله السابقه ان يحسن
امره مع هذا النظام المفروض عليه في
الواقع يعني جرب كل ال- ال- ال- ال- ال-
الحكومات يعني من خاتمي الاصلاح الى احمد
نجاد المتشدد الى روحاني المعتدل الى رئيس
المتشدد في ياسر وخبت امال هذه الشعوب في
ايران فلهذا الانتخابات الرئاسيه الاخيره
وقبل الانتخابات البرلمانيه اكدت همم يعني
عدم اقبال الناس على هذه الانتخابات
وتحويل اراء الناس واتجاهات الناس الى
العمل
تغيير بنيوي هذا النظام لازم ان يتغير لا
لا مجال لامر اخر لان في الواقع للمراه
تشعر
بالمساواه في المجتمع الايراني ولا غير
الفارسي يشعر بالتكافؤ في يوسف العزيزي
الى اين يمكن ان تصل هذه المظاهرات انت
تقول ان المظاهرات الحاليه هي مختلفه عن
سابقاتها ان كان في 2009 او 2019 الى اين
يمكن ان تصل هذه المظاهرات الحاليه في
ايران
واذا اذا اذا صمد
واستمر في غمره وشدد
وتطوره الى جمع السوري في ايران ستشهد همم
مرحله اشد
وستتفكك البلاد يعني ممكن حتى تكون حرب
اهليه لكن اذا خامني استمع الى صوت الشعب
كما استمع الشاه في اخر ايام فيمكن ان تحل
المساله
باقل التضحيات الممكنه وبغل الدماء التي
مشكله
الشعب واحد الشعب الفارسي على الشعوب
الاخرى همم
التمييز الجنسي ضد المراه الفاحش والتفاوت
الطبغي في ايران الذي لم يشهده حتى حكم
الشرع
اصبحت يعني تستثمر
الطبقه العام
المسحوبه استاذ حسن تحدثنا عن همم تاثير
هذه المظاهرات داخليه لكن خارجيا ايضا كان
لها تاثير يعني قبل المظاهرات كان هناك
ترقب لي احياء وشيك للاتفاق النووي
وعوده امريكا الى الى الاتفاق مع ايران هل
برايك هذه المظاهرات يعني كان لها
انعكاسات سلبيه كبيره على النظام الايراني
كذلك في ملفات خارجيه اخرى
اه حتما ان هذه المظاهرات وهذه الحركه
الاحتجاجيه كان لا تاثير واضح على على
المواقف الدوليه في التعاطي مع ايران وعلى
الجهود التي كان يبذلها النظام للتواصل مع
المجتمع الدولي ومن بوابه الملف النووي
واعاده احياء من الاتفاق عام 2015
لا يريد اي من الاطراف الدوليه وتحديدا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اعلان وفاته
النهائيه نعم وانما دخلته في همم
موت سريري وخاصه وان
هذه العواصم الدوليه التركيه الاوروبيه
التي ذهبت الى التصعيد بوجه النظام
الايراني لفرض على عقوبات غير مسبوقه عليه
في الموضوع لحقوق الانسان
وهذا هو ادت ايضا الى اخراج في سابقه لم
تشهدها همم لجان لجنه المراه في الامم
المتحده التي تاسست منذ 15 عاما همم ان ان
يطرد احد الاعضاء منها
نتيجه الممارسات القميعيه التي تمارس بحق
المراه وحق والمتظاهرين والمعترضين لذلك
همم
ما حدثته هذه الانتفاضه الدخل الايراني
ايضا انتقل الى ساحه الدوليه والعلاقات
الدوليه مع النظام الايراني الذي دخل في
همم او ذهب نحو تاجيل كل همم امكانيات
التفاوض مع مع طهران بانتظار سي ستقول
اليه همم الاوضاع الداخليه
وقدره النظام على الاستجابه للمطالب
الشعبيه
وبدء في مسار تغيير الذاتي او اعاده انتاج
النظام على اسس جديده ورؤيه جديده اشكركم
شكرا جزيلا ضيفيا الكريمين من بيروت حسن
فحص الكاتب الصحافي ومن لندن يوسف عزيزي
الباحث في الشان الايراني
[موسيقى]